certains pays de l'ue prépare lors
déconfinement illustration en allemagne
où dès lundi le port du masque sera
obligatoire dans certaines régions
notamment à kiel près de strasbourg
emilie vous gâche avec des images de
patrick herbert après des semaines de
confinement les rues allemandes
reviennent peu à peu à la vie si les
boutiques ont rouvert
on se prépare désormais à respecter une
autre obligation celle de porter de quoi
éviter de contaminer les autres masques
écharpe ou foulard une mesure plutôt
bien accueilli par les habitants de quel
iphone en fait et je trouve ça très bien
je comprends que beaucoup de personnes
ont un problème avec et qu'elle ne
souhaite pas le porter mais je trouve
qu'il faut le respecter
ce sont des mesures qui sont
obligatoires car on ne se protège pas
seulement nous mêmes vous êtes nombreux
neige les autres personnes je trouve que
c'est très bien ça nous permet de nous
protéger en nous et des autres c'est une
bonne initiative fans si tout le monde
peut le faire sachant que c'est vrai
qu'il est pas très compliqué alors je
trouve que c'est très bien pour faire
face à l'afflux des demandes
on peut trouver des masques assez
facilement il est par exemple possible
de se fournir dans les pharmacies plutôt
bien achalandé des masques ffp2 ils sont
notamment disponibles à la vente dans
les magasins qui ont pu lever le rideau
en début de semaine certains se sont
préparés à l'avant ce avant même
l'annoncé de cette obligation
l'office du tourisme de la ville a
d'ailleurs vendu ses derniers masque en
tissu en milieu de semaine et j'avais
sanaa masse qui si j'avais été aussi
font un acte qu'elle l'a donnée ont
donné j'avais acheté donnait pas j'ai
bien joué j'avais déjà tôt oui même
chose dans cette boutique de vêtements
où tout est prévu même pour les clients
qui nourrit pas leur masque à son ex qui
les frappent liste on tasse à partir de
la semaine prochaine nous avons
l'obligation que le client portant
des masques à usage unique pour l'infini
ils leur seront offerts nous attendons
encore des masques en tissu dès la
semaine prochaine ils seront offerts aux
clientes puissent porter des masques
confortable treize des seize länder
allemands ont choisi de contraindre
leurs habitants à porter le masque mais
pas d'obligation à l'échelle de cet état
fédéral où la propagation de la pandémie
semble toujours se contrôler